foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22 a
new program from The Spectator where we
take a different or original look at the
week's news I am joined today by Damien
Reilly who is a frequent contributor to
The Spectator and we're going to be
talking about Dana Dana am I pronouncing
that and Dana Dana White and the UFC now
Damien explain for us a little bit
um about Dana White's latest
escapades he's been filmed slapping his
wife in a nightclub
uh and you wrote a very good piece for
the spectator last week saying and I
think uh most people agreed with you
from what I could gather
um that of course he has to go it's not
acceptable for Dana White to uh keep his
job as head of the Ultimate Fighting
Championship if he is publicly known to
be a wife slapper
that's right it's an extraordinary
situation this footage emerged on
January the second or third uh taken on
New Year's Eve celebrations in a
nightclub in Mexico in it you can see it
looks like he said something that's
upset his wife then I think it's a bit
of the footage is cut then you see him
trying to talk to her uh and and she
slapped him and instinctively he just
slaps her back across the face so he
strikes his wife
um it's very obviously a very incendiary
thing to happen he has hit a woman and
yet he seems to be uh trying to style it
out or keep his job it's not it's a it
seems an extraordinary turn of events
for someone who hits women to remain in
their job and tell us a bit about Dana
White because he's an extremely powerful
figure in this world probably a lot of
our viewers don't know much about but it
is huge it's Mega business it's an
enormous sport all over the world and
Dana White is the king it's complete
Ultraviolence it's um
it's wonderfully free of rules in a way
there's it's mixed martial arts so it's
all the different forms of martial arts
uh in one fight
um I think you can't eye gouge or bite
or headbutt but other than that kind of
anything goes it's incredibly violent
um to people who are not initiated to
watch it I mean it can be quite
horrifying at first it's hugely
horrifying people but that's appeal to
someone like you you like that yeah I
mean I didn't realize like I enjoyed it
until I got to about 40 and then
suddenly it all made sense but it's um
it does it can appear from the out from
the outside terrifically barbaric
um but the more you watch The More You
observe it the more you get to know
what's going on there's a great deal of
nuance and complexity to it that is
quite satisfying well a large part of
the sport now is women's cage fighting
yeah
um and of course I suppose it adds an
element to this story which is that she
slapped him
uh in this fight in a bar and he slapped
her back I mean I think there have been
cage fights between men and women if
they're not I think there was one but it
certainly wasn't sanctioned by the UFC
it's pretty awful I think I mean in the
the you know the debate that rages
around people being able to change
gender easily and compete men trans
women competing in women's sport uh I
think that was kind of an outlier in
that that there was a I think there was
a man who was fairly successful in or
trans trans woman who was fairly
successful in women's fighting
um yeah so I don't but I don't think
this can be put into that category but
you you don't watch do you watch the
women's cage fighting it's a bit it's a
bit sporty for my my tastes I can't yeah
I don't I can't I I don't enjoy it
particularly seeing the women fighting
but from an egalitarian perspective you
see that it's you know it's fair it's
fair game I think if they want to fight
they're completely allowed to fight a
lot of them have come from terrifically
difficult backgrounds I mean that quite
often poverty and there's kind right
there's a there are a fair few UFC my
UFC fighters who have been victims of
domestic violence
um and so it kind of makes it all the
worse there uh yeah it's not great is
Dana White going to lose his job do you
think well that's what's so fascinating
he is he is imposed he has he's trying
to
he's gone very quiet he hasn't uh he
made a statement about it in a
terrifically sympathetic interview with
TMZ who are the people that first
released the footage they didn't release
the footage until they had a comment
from him
um they were they're kind of you know
they get great access to the UFC and
they have done traditionally so they
were they gave a very very softball
interview with him saying you know there
was a lot of alcohol involved do you and
do you even remember it you know it's
just between you and your wife he's
apologized to her he says she has
released a statement saying that it's
never happened before which I suppose is
very unfortunate the first time it ever
happened it was caught on camera and
what are the chances uh and uh yeah so
that's where we are he the share price
fell of the Endeavor Group which owns
the UFC the share price fell in the days
after it happened a few percent five
percent it hasn't seemed to have fallen
too much further and so maybe he will
keep his job he doesn't seem to be going
anywhere can anybody remove him if he
doesn't want to go
yes because he is the president but it
is owned by the Endeavor group so the
Endeavor group presumably could get rid
of him he is I think he has an equity
stake nobody knows what his Equity stake
is I think it originally was it was
about nine percent but then it got sold
to the Endeavor group and he says they
gave him a stake no Purina knows what it
is but yes if if public opinion turns
sufficiently violently against him I'm
sure they could get rid of him but they
don't seem to be doing it he's I mean I
know UFC is global but it's probably
biggest in America is that fair to say
uh yeah it's big in America but it's
massive in the Middle East to speak in
this country huge in Russia big
throughout Europe it's it's Global but
it's uh I mean it is sort of connected
to populism isn't it in that
um Donald Trump
uh had connections with WWF which is the
fake wrestling uh I shouldn't say that
probably get a big trouble saying that
but um the the less real wrestling let's
say uh and then Dana White was uh close
to Trump they did they knew they know
each other their powers well massively
and Donald Trump I think in the early
days of the UFC he staged some fights in
his hotels so he got into it quite early
I don't know if he is a huge fan of it
but Dana White is certainly a very high
profile Trump supporter as for populism
I don't know about that but I do suspect
that UFC fans and certainly UFC fighters
tend towards the right there's a there's
not too much
um
this you certainly wouldn't say there's
too much of the progressive uh nature to
the UFC there's notes talking of
pronouns or transgressions or
microaggressions yeah uh it's all a bit
more
fighty than that do you what would you
say to people who have slightly maybe
fogish instincts like me who think
you know when you sanction Ultraviolence
when you turn it into entertainment uh
can you be that horrified that the head
of it is a violent person
I suppose the whole uh sport is built
upon the idea of very controlled
violence and regulated violence and also
martial arts are generally about
self-defense or
um
I suppose looking after people who are
vulnerable I suppose if you're great at
fighting but
I think
I think uh uh I think having not done it
myself but I suspect uh the first thing
martial artists learn is that you should
never attack people who are vulnerable
or are unable to defend themselves
adequately against you I don't think
it's okay I don't think it's okay to say
that hitting your wife is all right
because your job is ahead of a of a of
the UFC well I suppose what I'm driving
out is that it's odd that
um UFC has is so big it is a
multi-billion Dollar business as you say
and yet quite a lot of people know
nothing about it whereas something like
boxing you would probably know who
mostly even if you're not interested at
all you'd probably know who Mike Tyson
is but there's probably large chunks of
the population who don't know who Conor
McGregor say is I don't know if that's
true Conor McGregor is the the last one
he's been out for a year but before that
he was the second or third highest paid
athlete in the world sort of just behind
Ronaldo and LeBron James I mean he is
massive he's truly famous but I agree
people don't don't know the people The
Wider public probably don't follow kids
fighting are very very surprised of many
spectator uh subscribers do or spectator
readers perhaps they do but it's only
been around since 2021 really since Dana
White and in just two decades it's grown
phenomenally fast and it shows no sign
of slowing no one has ever died in the
Octagon is it even called the octagon
it's called The Octagon yeah yeah it's
called The Octagon I don't think
anyone's died wouldn't I know no one's
died as people have probably sustained
terrible injuries that have affected
them later on but it does always seem to
be a fairly injury-free surprisingly
injury-free given what they do to each
other
um well given that it is such a uh Big
World Sport and everybody's so many
people are interested in it apart from
your article I have not seen much of a
clamor
for Dana White to go is that just
because of the power he wields I think
so so I think that's extraordinary there
has been such a muted response from both
the journalists who cover the sport and
from the fighters to get rid of him in
fact there's been the opposite a great
deal of fans people have been commenting
to me or sending me tweets beneath the
article and across social media you can
see there is a strange number of people
defending what Dana White has done
there's a lot of suspicion that there's
deep misogyny within UFC because it's
sort of thought to be bro culture people
think Andrew Tate uh the now notorious
misogynist is associated with it
although I believe he's more of a
kickboxer than he was more of a
kickboxing fighter but the Joe Rogan the
very famous podcaster very broy
podcaster uh is a announcer a
commentator yeah it's all UFC
um and so a lot of people want to attack
it as this misogynist dick sport even if
there is a big women's part to it and
this story as you say in your piece
gives sucker to those people massively
so I think
um I think previously the accusations of
misogyny or the general feeling of
misogyny
was uh misplaced or at least
defendable against
um there were there are certainly
Fighters within the UFC who have been
caught up in domestic abuse troubles and
some of that is pretty bad however there
is simply no way now that the president
of the entire show
has has been seen on camera doing it to
be able to say that there's it's free of
misogyny or free of domestic violence if
the the president the whole organization
has done it without any sanctional
repercussion then the precedent it sets
is unbelievable there's uh any any time
in future one of the fighters does it or
somebody involved in the organization
does something similar
or in fact any fan or anyone who looks
up to the fighters or to Dana White as a
as a role model which many many people
will do
um what type what type of example is it
setting so for you as a Dana White fan
Dana Moscow Dana must certainly go
there's no two ways about it it's
Unthinkable that he continues I think
but yet here we are how many days 10
days 10 days in yeah since the footage
became public uh and no movement and I
think that in itself is is interesting
we talk constantly about cancer culture
and people being canceled for all sorts
of things and yet here we are there's
something terrible has happened
something there is hard evidence that's
happened
um and yet if you don't if you're
sufficiently powerful uh and uh
sufficiently able to just get your head
down and and try and batten down the
hatches then perhaps you can be immune
to cancer culture for something that
which is obviously egregious do you
think it makes a difference that his
wife has appears to have forgiven him I
mean she could otherwise take him to
court or have him arrested for it so it
makes a huge difference
um and I suppose it maybe it provokes a
wider debate about how much really does
this stuff go on and does the typical
UFC fan
think well you know they're but for the
grace of God or it's uh
yeah how unusual is domestic violence or
amongst UFC fans uh how unusual is it
generally I don't know it's uh well
people keep saying we're living through
an epidemic of violence against women I
tend to be skeptical of that about that
I think there's always been violence
against women I don't think it's
particularly stronger now than it has
been if anything I'd say it's weaker but
I take your point that this incident
doesn't help the UFC it doesn't have a
UFC at all but it also is instructive
the amount of people who have taken to
public forums and social media to defend
it I mean that seems amazing there are
other
uh you know we put there are other
crimes which society puts on the same
level as as hitting a woman if you're a
man
um and it I could you know it seems
unimaginable that people would defend
those publicly if they if they are you
just talking about camera are you just
talking about people on social media
defending or are you talking about
leading figures within the sport saying
yes uh well there are fighters who have
come out and said it you know she hit
him first and it's kind of okay
but there's also a complete lack of well
not a complete but a huge lack of the
sports journalists taking a stance
against it and that's because uh if
Dana's was to survive the Scandal which
he looks more and more like doing then
he will still be in position and he will
have complete say over how they progress
in their careers there's a journalist
called Ariel hawani who every year since
2010 has won um the mma's leading or
best journalist and in 2016 he
transgressed Dana White and I think he
broke an embargo on a story but it was
kind of a ridiculous embargo about a
fighter returning to the UFC and he'd
also questioned or raised questions
about uh pay the amount of money the
fighters are paid which is often kind of
scandalous how little they get paid and
as a result Dana White issued a lifetime
ban for him he was working for ESPN so
he couldn't attend any UFC conferences
it was subsequently lifted but it showed
the power he had without with that ban
in place he completely unable to do his
job well that's often when I've the
interest I've taken in UFC limited as it
is that's often what I thought is that
the fighting's very real but everything
around it seems quite fake uh and Dana
White sort of pulls all the strings uh
the press conferences are clearly
orchestrated by him who fights who is
clearly chosen by him uh it's it's sort
of WWF outside the ring isn't it I
disagree with that because I think it's
I mean the tagline of UFC is as real as
it gets that's what the whole thing is
it's meant to be very real yeah
and the obviously the WWE or whatever f
is is complete pantomime
um but this isn't the the characters
within it seem cartoonish and they are
cartoonish because they seem to be
blissfully free of society's Norms they
fight for a living uh they can do and
say largely whatever they like because
they're not hide Bound By any any sort
of canceled culture cancel culture or
constraints of politeness or whatever
what they're doing is beyond that
um and they are larger than life in
every every way but often many of them
are sort of fundamentally very good
people
um yeah and so it's kind of disgusting
to see that the guy who's in charge of
the whole thing
um is obviously cut from a slightly
different cloth in terms of the the
fights uh and putting the fights
together it is far more honest as a
sport than say boxing where boxer
Fighters avoid each other for years on
end whereas in the UFC they're put
together the best fights the best and
it's constant constant constant so it's
always incredibly exciting
you are clearly quite passionate about
the idea that Dana has to go uh will you
keep campaigning on this issue uh if he
does not
well uh I don't know what else is there
to write I mean I've said he should go
he's not going I don't know uh yes I
probably would I would it'd be hard to
see him in a UFC fight he comes out and
puts the belt around the winners
and it's uh oh it'd be hard not to have
a you know to think badly of him every
time you see him now that that man hits
women
um it leaves a nasty taste in the mouth
I guess he also pushes them apart
doesn't he win fighting yeah when they
do the squaring up thing he loves
stepping yeah yeah yeah yeah and most
people will think of the because most
people who are interested have now seen
the video of him
I guess also I mean there's a aspect of
it as well your the Legacy that anybody
has he's built it's it's rather sad he's
built a multi-billion dollar industry
kind of out of nothing uh
and that's an amazing achievement he's
taking it International he's got it
televised all these other amazing things
but ultimately the thing he will now be
remembered for uh will be this footage
you can't if you if you hit a woman in
public
there's no uh there's no raising that
from everybody's minds and I don't see
how uh it's not it's not just ignoring
it isn't going to make it go away
well Damian thank you very much for
coming into the spectators octagon the
view from 22. thank you uh and please
come on again
[Music]